moi je suis originaire de la région j'ai
une maison à sept kilomètres d'ici donc
c'est tout naturellement qu'on venait le
week-end achetez achetez nos baguettes
et c est un samedi matin en revenant
j'ai vu que la boulangerie été fermée
avec un gros encarts écrire liquidation
judiciaire vente aux enchères à venir en
voyant ça j'en ai parlé à juliette ma
tante et en rigolant s'est dit tiens ce
serait vraiment un rêve de pouvoir
refaire vivre cette boulangerie on s'est
revus trois semaines plus tard avec un
de mes cousins les partis tous ensemble
de sur un rêve un peu fou c'est de se
dire à léon ont fait une offre à la
vente aux enchères pour récupérer le
fonds de commerce
et puis on verra on verra bien ce qui se
passe est le jour de la vente aux
enchères arrive on fait une offre et on
gagne donc on remporte la boulangerie et
on se retrouve tous les trois
propriétaire du fonds de commerce d'une
boulangerie arrive à m on est tous les
trois originaires des 6000 ans vit dans
des régions différentes geoffroy vit en
normandie moi je vis à paris et juliette
à aix-en-provence et on revient
régulièrement pour des week-ends pour
pour des vacances
donc là on a ouvert il ya trois mois
finalement donc on est très content la
boulangerie est ouverte tous les jours
merci monsieur bonne journée un paon 22
on a une tradition on a une belle gueule
de campagne qu'il faut le vin naturel on
a une baguette céréales et une baguette
blanche classique
si vous lui à travers le concept du
petit marius mettre en avant des
produits locaux de nos trois régions
voilà ces produits triés sur le volet
dont qu'on a un caramel de pommes
dieppois on a du cidre d'un producteur
local de la région de geoffroy
l'objectif ce n'est pas de tirer les
bénéfices de la boulangerie c'est de
faire vivre cette boulangerie donc de
pouvoir payer dans salariés
langeree qui ferment par jour en france
trois boulangeries dans des zones
rurales
donc on n'est pas des warriors on n'est
pas meilleurs que les autres
on a un concept qui est un peu différent
où nous on va s'occuper de nous associer
vraiment de la partie gestion
administrative rh on s'occupe à la
production quotidienne
c'est dans le métier de notre boulanger
qui s'appelle baptiste qui se fait
focalisé vraiment sur la production et
qui on va dire ne va pas polluer son
quotidien par des tâches administratives
qui sont à notre charge
leurrer on est dans un village de 580
personnes avec une zone de chalandise de
2005 à 3000 personnes
mais il faut que les habitants jouent le
jeu en fait les gens peuvent râler sur
la grande distribution mais au final et
tout ça beaucoup plus simple une fois et
ils achètent tous leurs produits
l'enjeu il est crucial c'est que les
habitants des communes alentours les
habitants locaux vraiment prennent leurs
habitudes et de venir régulièrement pour
faire vivre ce commerce
sinon bah on ne pourra pas on pourra pas
résister
[Musique]